since last september patricia has been
working at the convenience store down
the road so we have to think about where
they've underlined right over here this
has been working do we want to go with
that and the first choice is always
exactly as they wrote it right over here
so they wrote has been working they
wrote has been working over there so do
we want to go it with it as it's written
which is always going to be the first
choice or do we think one of these other
choices is going to make more sense so
since last september patricia has been
working at the convenience store down
the road
well has been working actually looks
pretty good looks pretty good because
we're not talking about something that
just happened in the past tense so if
this is last so this is a timeline right
over here and if this is last september
she starts working last september but
then she keeps working
since
since then so we want something that is
both that starts in the past but then
keeps going on through the future and so
that's what has been working does for us
now let's think about the other choices
and see why they don't quite do that so
if we used works works is the present
tense he that would mean that she's only
doing it right now it doesn't mean that
she's been doing it starting at some
period in the past and continuing to do
it all the way through right now so if
we said since last september patricia
works at the convenience store down the
road then we got we essentially have the
verb tense wrong because this is
starting in the past and continuing
while this is just just the present
since last september patricia is working
at the convenience store down the road
so once again this one is talking about
the present while we want something that
goes that starts in the past and then
continues through the present so this
one is only the present
since last september patricia will be
working well this is now occurring in
the future and that's not what since
last september is trying to talk about
since last september we want to go the
past into the present so we want to we
will we'll throw out that will be
working kind of implies that well we're
really talking about about the future
and since last september patricia worked
so this is strictly the past it's not
really talking about the past and
continuing through the present so since
last september patricia worked that's
kind of like hey she had worked and
maybe she's not working anymore but we
want to convey that she started working
then and she's continuing to work so has
been working seems to make the most
sense